You did a lot of singing on the set
to calm your nerves, Jeff, is that right?
Taron and I...
We both love music and we ended up breaking out in song
in the make-up trailer.
You and Taron would sing together?
We sang, what was it?
♫ What's in the Daily News
♫ I'll tell you what's in the Daily News
(audience cheers)
A story about what?
♫ A story about a Minnesota man so in love
♫ With a Mississippi girl that he sacrifices everything
♫ And moves all the way to Bil-uh-something
(cheering and clapping)
I swear, I swear we haven't done that for a year
and we didn't practice, at all, right?
That's right.
♫ Yes sir, when you see a guy
♫ Reach for stars in the sky
♫ yeah
Keep going, that-
♫ He's doing it for some doll
That's all.
(cheering and applause)
Total commitment!
(laughs)
I wanna see "Guys and Dolls" with The Dude in it.
Don't you now?